- All right, everybody.
We have reached the part of the show
where I share something heartwarming
from the internet that you may like.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
More men than ever are rocking nail art.
Musicians like Harry Styles,
Bad Bunny, ASAP Rocky,
all have amazing nails.
So when a preschool boy
was told by his teacher
that boys don't paint
their nails, shame on you.
His dad had the best reaction.
- Yesterday, my son came home
from school really upset,
because his teacher told him
that painting your
nails is only for girls.
So today I'm taking 'em to the nail shop.
- Yeah.
- [Dad] Ooh.
- Pink.
- [Dad] Pick one.
- Um, this one.
- [Dad] Okay.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- I swear that's my son, y'all.
He's the same kid.
And let's get Ashton and
his dad, Christian in here.
What's up, y'all?
- Hi.
- What's up?
So Ashton, first, let's see your nails.
Do you like 'em?
- Let's see it, bud, show 'em.
- Oh, I love 'em.
- Yeah.
Ashton, I have my son, he's
six and his name is Remy.
Remy B, he makes me say
that, but he loves blue.
His nails are blue as well.
He loves blue nail polish.
That's his favorite thing.
So Christian, you say that you saw this
as a way to take something sad
and make it positive, right?
- These nails are this blue.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Yeah.
- So, my family's always been,
you know, a little different.
And we love living in color.
So, when Ashton came home upset
I was a little upset myself,
you know what I mean?
When she said, "It's just for girls."
I was like, "What?"
But I'm also a teacher
and I look for these teaching moments.
I didn't wanna go full Karen
and go up to the school all mad.
So instead, I took him to the nail shop,
he picked out hot pink himself.
We painted our nails
and we had a good time and it was awesome.
- I love it.
First of all, thank you so
much for being a teacher.
First of all, that's an amazing
thing to do for everyone.
- Dad.
- Yeah.
Well, I was a little
upset when I heard that
'cause somebody told my son as well,
that you're a boy, you
can't wear nail polish.
And I let him pick
whatever color he wanted.
I was like, what?
This is not the fifties.
Okay.
But Christian, you did
another thing off camera
that deserves just as much attention.
So, tell us about that.
- Okay, so ultimately I
decided not to go complain
to the school administration, right?
So I went and I talked to her, right?
Instead of canceling her.
So many people on TikTok were like--
- Hi, Kelly.
- Trying to go for her job
and like trying to have her fired.
But that's really not
me, you know what I mean?
I think we all just need to talk
to each other a little bit more.
- That's the coolest thing ever, man.
And what a way to teach your
son how to react, you know?
That's the most important thing.
It's things are gonna happen to us,
but it's how we react is who we are.
Thank you so much.
Ashton, I love your nails.
I love your nails as well, Christian.
- Say thank you.
- I'm liking y'alls post right now.
And that's not all.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
wanna celebrate families just like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- What?
What?
- That's a lot of nail polish.
Thank you guys so much
and thank you to all our guests this hour,
Henry Winkler, Melissa
Barrera, Brian Hart Hoffman,
Kay Adams, and Jackson Dean.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.